What is Metadata Well Literally It is Data about Data so?
Let's Look at some examples, We often Have associated with A?
Cd track you know There's online Databases That Associate With it who's the Artist and How Long the track Is
Where it was Recorded I Would all be Metadata?
Part of Standards Around Jpeg and Commonly use the Compression Mechanism There is A
Exchangeable Image file Format Feels except it's called which tags the image with Various Pieces of Useful Information
The Digital Cameras will put in all of the Information you know so the exposure Time the Camera settings when the flash
We use the whole bunch of things that put in There very Rich you know Amount of Metadata Can, also put in Things like?
Location so if you wander a high you Take a Picture in your
Smartphone You Upload it to some Service and They do Locate it they Show it on a map
That's Because The Gps Coordinates are in There as, well People Should be very
Aware of that for Fear that they want to Take a picture Somewhere and They
Don't want to Trace to their eyes and Some People I've Had some rather Embarrassing
Consequences When That's happened one of the other Things that?
Professional Photographers will often do Is they will put in Copyright Information Information about who Owns the Copyright or perhaps who you Could Contact
To
License The image They might even Create in the License that it's available under
Especially if it's Settled License Is called A creative Commons
Licenses Which
Were Available that to Say how People Can Reuse an image so that when you find an Image with A creative Commons
License you Know Whether you Can you know Share it on whether you could Modify it Whether you can use it for Commercial or Non-Commercial
Use and indeed if You go in to google Image search and go to the advanced search Options you can
Actually Search By, License Type you can
Say I want an image that's Freely Reusable or modifiable if You want to create a powerpoint or something?
and you want to be
Legal Honest and decent With Copyright law then you should Actually be Making sure you have images that
Have that Sort of Copyright License associated with them as A professionals will often put in you know Just
Name Or email Address on a Website and Say it's Copyright Me and
This is how you Contact me to get a license of Course the most People Contacting a photographer to get a license
It's just it's just way too much Work, and so most People have Taken A very Simple Expedient of Saying
Well don't worry about it then in fact the reach of images that are There in Violation of Copyright is Pretty extreme I'm
Justifiably very Many professionals Open Arms but This
There's A number of Things that you'd Say like this the first Thing Is
Most digital tools were Shockingly Bad at maintaining the
Image Method Theatres Across Editing so Many, of them will Just Crop it out Throw it away
Of Course Many People when They See a picture they?
Really Like and want to use they
Don't Actually save These Messages to A screen Shot at which Point the Screen Shop
Doesn't Propagate The Metadata That May be associated With the image Is caught in the Scene
Not if There's several Images it might be Hard to Figure out Which netted A does it Take
Metadata and Their Data Are Easily Parted and it happens A lot and you'll See People Uploading Images to
Web Websites it May Have Perfectly good Metadata in it but the Matter the Website will Strip, that I
It is a Matter of Concern Because so many People Make Their
Businesses Out of That Sort of Copyright Material
One of the Challenges Is getting the Copyright often Involves Picking up the Phone and Talking to someone and if The Person on the other
End is a lawyer and you're Negotiating
Access it's going to cost you Hundreds of Pounds Because that's how much a lawyer charges to pick up a Phone so the
Human Being Second Isms of Copyright Licensing Mean that it tends to be an expensive Business but that's Where We Should ask the Question?
You know Could, We Build a digital Means of Accessing Material?
That Had the Transaction Cost that you Would Expect with A?
Digital Transaction Which is the Transaction cost very very Little and
The Money you'd be Paying for the image Would be going to the artist Or a photographer or Whatever
And not to the legal Negotiation to get There and so for example in the uk the
Copyright Hub and There's A Company Behind That being Promoted by the intellectual Property Office to actually build an online
Exchange so you'll be able to go along and and for the Transaction costs of Pence and Maybe Pines
and you Would be able to get you know Access to Imagery that you could use Whether it's your Powerpoint your Company Brochure and the
Whole idea is to remove Friction as the way the connected Digital Economy catapult Puts it
They Talk About Removing The Friction from Copyright Licensing because Digital Transactions in This Space Should
Be you know the Transaction Itself costs Fractions of a Pence and then you're Just Paying the
You know for the image rights to reuse it and I think at
The Point at Which you know That Becomes A prevalent way of Operating and the cost, Structures right then Actually you know People
will
Stretch But Certainly There's Working for Corporate Support They want they want to be legal and Respect Copyright and We Simply haven't Today given the?
Technology tools That enable People
But We do Have These mechanisms for Buying Music if not License
When you Buy it you are Licensing it you are
Licensing it for your personal Use and a religion Change the law in the uk means that you Can switch it between
Formats Format Switching As Long as it's for your own personal use when you don't Buy Something from
Itunes Or Something However You are Engaging it's in The Terms of Conditions that in Their Copyright License You've got a license
To use it for your own personal use
But We did See the same thing a number of Years Ago until Those legal exchanges Came available Where you could get Music
People were Frustrated and They Had These Grid MP3 Players and a Stack of CDS and
It Seemed Perfectly Legitimate to them to take the bits off the CD and put it on the MP3 Player
The Music Industry Took A long Time to wake up to that and Realize that they Should Simply
Be the Channel That collects That Revenue and if You Make it Easy and Simple to use then
Maybe People Would be Willing to do that what they wanted was a convenience and Give Them the Convenience then Many People?
Perfectly Happy To at legally
I
Encrypt something With my private Keys and then your public key and then send it to you and
If We communicate like This I know that Nobody Else Coming Frequencies in The Amplitude and the Fears Within?
That 3.4 Coverage Ban in Order to get Ourselves Nearly up to 56 Kilobits